i am so excited for 8-bit christmas i
can't even handle it because when you
have young kids and you know you're
gonna be watching a movie throughout the
whole holiday season and probably the
next few years
this looks so good i am
excited to ask you some christmas
questions some holiday themed questions
it's a little game called tell the truth
[Music]
who is the most famous person who gave
you a gift and what was it whoopi
goldberg
when i did my first movie called clara's
heart of course that christmas and i had
just
filmed a movie with whoopi goldberg in
my small town in new mexico i got this
gigantic box and inside was a stuffed uh
elephant plush from fao schwartz it was
as big as i mean it was huge and i it
was gigantic i've never seen a stuffed
animal like that before and it was from
whoopi goldberg do you judge other
people's holiday decor i only judge
other people's holiday decor when
they're really proud of it and it all
comes from big giant like box stores
don't have olaf from frozen next to like
a vampire next to elves there's you need
a theme
come on drew you need a theme if you're
gonna do some decorating how do you
accept a terrible gift
so graciously
this for for me
oh
i
have never
what is the worst gift david ever gave
you i said that i wanted a bracelet i
wanted a really simple bracelet like
that you could wear all the time and
he got me a bracelet but not at all
simple he got me one that was very super
ornate and fancy
and he'd spent you know bracelets aren't
inexpensive but it isn't all what i
wanted i was pretty clear about a
specific you know jewelry you want to
have jewelry this specifically i am so
excited for 8-bit christmas i can't even
handle it this script came along and
it's sort of an 80s take on a christmas
story yes but instead of a bb gun he
wants a nintendo entertainment game
system and i just thought that was
it was really funny i think the movie
plays really well it's fun for adults
it's fun for kids and i think it's good
enough it could be watched in
year after year like a perennial kind of
thing i think this is a classic in the
making and i think adults
we
we did get movies in the 80s that
serviced both children and parents
totally the 70s and 80s didn't talk down
to kids
it was about the whole family it was
about adults and that simpsons rule of
you can
speak to everyone
i am so excited for this movie like i
need this i feel like this is
what we have been waiting for i'm not
kidding i'm so excited i just really i
have to like thank you because you're
gonna save my christmas hey at least for
an hour and a half oh my gosh i i love
christmas movies they are something that
you do over and over and over so that's
why i think it's a classic in the making
watching emma daughter's jug band
christmas watching it's a wonderful life
watching 8-bit christmas you know like
being able to have the same traditions
over and over is a big part of the
holiday and my uncle my great-uncle
lionel is potter which is so fun wow
barrymore oh my god that's right no
that's cool he was in a wheelchair in
real life wow and that you know that
doesn't stop the berry mars we try to
show it more often to our kids but when
they see black and white movies that
were filmed on film they say that it's
blurry this is the age of our children i
know they think that if something's
filmed on film instead of digitally it's
blurry i know so i gotta i gotta take
them to an actual cinema let me ask you
about wondercade because oh yeah you
know how much i love box one and your
games i feel like if somebody said i
want you to paint a picture of
neil patrick harris's style i could what
would that be cocktail
old-fashioned
a hint of
magician there's a modernity to it oh i
love that it is not eternity future do
you ever feel like you were born in the
wrong era i always loved the magicians
that did that traveled on trains
thurston and dante and everyone went to
see their shows in tuxedos and top hats
and velvet seats yeah yeah i thought
that was wonderful that period and so
i've always loved textures and things
that were tactile and wonderkate i
thought was a fun opportunity to be able
to talk about things that i've done talk
about things that i like talk about
things that one can acquire
recommendations and things yeah in a
single place you know an email a
newsletter and it's really written like
a newsletter you can look it on your
phone and you can scroll
through it but it feels it's even broken
down into acts almost like a variety
show and there's interviews i
interviewed
the new doogie hauser i had a doogie
doogie interview it's sort of like a
gentleman's goop but a little less
viscous if you're a female it all it's
great because you can look at things to
buy for your man and if you're a man
it's helpful you can learn some skills
to make your life more entertaining
here's the thing also wondercade is a
word that didn't really exist before so
i created the weird word and i think
it's easy to say i love gentlemen's goop
that actually is super fun there isn't
that out there
there is no
and we're all coming to the party
every kid has that one gift they want
more than anything for christmas
this is the story of mine
bookends and they have baseballs on them
i see that no not those nintendo
a maze of rubber wiring and electronic
intelligence so advanced it was deemed
not a video game but an 8-bit
entertainment system
no nintendo on my house i second that
looks like a no-go on nintendo
i needed a christmas miracle
the year was 1987 or was it 88 super
bowl was in it okay does it really
matter dad oh
okay the year was the late 80s i was 11
years old did you wear a helmet yeah we
always wore helmets in the 80s
[Music]
me and my friends would do anything just
to play one any of you huddled masters
on a plane
what have you brought me
untraceable cash money it's the final
downtime
one thing became clear i needed to get
my own
this is bigger than christmas
[Music]
this is our vietnam i don't think that
means what you think it means i have no
idea what it means we're gonna get in so
much trouble
sometimes during christmas just when you
think that all hope is lost something
magical happens
[Music]
sold out in 20 minutes suddenly one
woman punched a grandma right in the
throat
same family too
are you making all this up no no no way
did you guys hear in the race selling
contests first prize is a brand new
nintendo entertainment system
i'm gonna kill you
hold on
[Music]
there are no rules
that nintendo's mine
what do you want to buy a reef
ma this kid thinks your wreath sucks
video games
have been doing all kinds of strange
things to children
what it was the 80s stuff got real
red dog this is bluebird this is rainbow
one what happened to red dog i changed
it well let's change names now this is
millennium falcon super cool
love it rated pg
[Music]